like a suit of armor every piece is worn
with care every layer designed to keep
these doctors alive for they are
fighting a virus that has no cure and
infection now sweeping through this part
of Africa Ebola has struck in a city
called Beni and a medical charity called
Alima is grappling with the consequences
they've erected innovative
air-conditioned tents or cubes to treat
the most serious cases but the majority
are unlikely to survive it's
extraordinary how close you can get to a
patient infected with Ebola there's just
this thin plastic sheet separating us
from what they call the red zone it's an
otherworldly place and it is extremely
dangerous inside dr. abu bakr saleh took
our camera into a cube as he checked on
a woman called esther one of 300 people
to contract Ebola since the outbreak
began Esther's running a terrible fever
but she feels deathly cold as the virus
multiplies in her body
the doctor tells her to hold on but he
has nothing to offer but paracetamol and
food and water in the next tent we found
a girl called Maria the virus has killed
her mother and her father has abandoned
her so health workers are trying to
nurse her through typically Ebola
targets adults but this strain is
working differently there is little
dignity in death a 46 year old woman
died in tent number seven and the Red
Cross took the body away she was taken
to a Shack so family members could say
goodbye but they couldn't touch or
embrace her the virus lives on for days
medics like dr. junior are struggling to
cope in a field hospital that is well
over capacity effective or something on
the peak yeah in fact less you know who
the Casas babe
the legit luck Navi only confirming a
Porsche Audi approached this fast kazoo
school on Kayla logistic they emitted 92
patients on the day of our visit
including dozens of suspect cases who
were taken to a separate area for tests
fear hung heavily as they waited for the
results
it must be terrifying for people to be
here an anxious mother kuvira and her
son gay had spent 48 hours in the
suspect zone she said they felt like
outcasts it is a difficult place to be
anguished cries emanate from the
hospital morgue located just behind
kuvira's Hut 4 star for building a wall
so the patients can't see it still there
are some who have recovered after months
of sickness in fact 7 were released from
the hospital during our visit
[Music]
with a government official declaring
them officially clean among their number
is a baby called Pascal the first child
he said to overcome this viral strain
they have a difficult journey ahead for
many will shun and avoid them but this
group have done something remarkable
they have survived the Ebola virus John
sparks Sky News in the Democratic
Republic of Congo